we need relevant writers that can make
us relevant again is there anyone dead
we can revive maybe but he's not dead
who
harry shaw
he's dead beggar off
it's dragon
really i mean he's probably
did you know he shot his last assistant
because he mistook him for a bear oh
how is that even possible i don't
believe you can't believe everything oh
we're not bears we're not bears we asked
danbridge publishing believe that is
your signature so you owe us a book shut
up
anything you want to show me
your pound of flesh i won't do the
bloody tour do the tour or i edit the
book those are your choices
this is a book tour why don't i read
something
bullshite [ __ ] [ __ ]
no one's interested in the book they're
interested in this freak show this man
is the book reviewer for the times i
don't like book critics and i found it
totally pessimistic
you're all evil shite
it is not selling okay no one is buying
it i can't get him to do anything all i
am to him is his driver and his scotch
sherpa let's go do you want to buy a
book
you want to know what i think
[Music]
times have changed hashtags [ __ ] how
a book is released today has become just
as meaningful as its content eden was
gone no longer within reach god was done
with mistakes
was too melodramatic
you vanquished my fears for that
i am forever grateful he's made me nuts
hasn't he
i know
[Music]
mr shaw what is your book about be brave
be truthful
even the worst of us get lucky
somehow you have over 20 000 followers
christ had followers it didn't end well
for him bible was a bestseller wasn't it
you